good morning Hank it's Tuesday three
things first I went to Los Angeles a
couple days ago to watch a movie I don't
think I'm allowed to tell you the name
of the movie that I could hint at it it
comes out on June 6th it's funny but
then other times it's very very sad and
I really really loved it
so that's exciting and also a huge
relief I need to change shirts because I
match the wall alright that's better in
a totally unrelated story everyone
should read my book The Fault in Our
Stars before the movie adaptation comes
out on June 6th was I subtle they said I
needed to be subtle secondly AFC
Wimbledon had their first game as a team
sponsored by nerdfighteria I'm an
Internet kid and I love gifs and I love
Instagram pictures and I love YouTube
videos but there's something really
quite cool to the physicality of it to
seeing those physical boards around the
physical pitch designed by physical
nerdfighters some of whom live half a
physical world away from me and from the
stadium Wimbledon lost the game but the
long arc of history bends toward justice
so we'll be fine and lastly I get to
give away some money so nerdfighters
raised more than eight hundred sixty
thousand dollars in this year's project
for awesome after we paid a make and
ship project for awesome perks all the
remaining money goes to charities chosen
by nerdfighteria and today I get to
announce ten winning charities that each
receive $50,000 first the Harry Potter
Alliance which fights inequality and
illiteracy and once worked with
nerdfighteria to send five airplanes
worth of life-saving medical supplies to
Haiti after the earthquake there
secondly this star won't go out the
organisation set up in memory of Esther
Earl that provides direct support to
families of kids with cancer then
there's not forgotten they house feed
and educate children in Peru and forth
we have saved the children which works
around the world to fight poverty and
disease
if Liberty in North Korea which is one
of those organizations that helpfully
puts its mission statement in its name
6th child's play which provides gaming
systems to kids in children's hospitals
so they can beat me at FIFA 7th and 8th
we have to water charities the thirst
project and water.org ninth we have
partners for mental health in other
words organizations that tells you what
it does in its name and lastly
eh-oh which i'm probably mispronouncing
an organization that mobilizes young
people including a group of nerdfighters
in argentina to build houses for people
living in poverty around Latin America
so like all ten of those organizations
will receive $50,000 apiece from the
foundation or decrease worldsuck now
people are probably wondering what are
they going to
with the remaining 360,000 dollars are
they going to spend it all on pizza and
corndogs sadly no some of that's going
to go to producing and shipping like the
t-shirts and the women of YouTube
calendar however most of it will be
split among ten more winning charities
they are to write love on her arms the
office of letters and light the world
food project feeding America the Wayne
foundation pencils for kids women for
women international first book kiva.org
and Doctors Without Borders so there you
have it the twenty winning charities
from the 2013 project for awesome our
money is going to go to fight disease
and poverty and illiteracy and injustice
and I'm so grateful to everyone who
donated and also everyone who took the
time to vote so that we could be good
stewards of this money if you want to
learn more about these organizations
there are links in the doobly-doo thank
you again for being part of the project
for awesome with us as we say in my
hometown dftba
Hank I'll see you on Friday